[Musique]
mes amis ici dans le grand ouest
la situation peut vite dégénérer quand
il divo raconte des histoires pareilles
à chercher tu crois pas vous connaissez
l'histoire il ya deux catégories
d'hommes les chanceux et les autres les
faibles et forts les pêcheurs et les
années de changement ou vif
j'apprécierais que vous alliez déposer
votre arme dans le réceptacle qui se
trouve juste à côté des portes battantes
et si je refuse
israël qu'est ce que tu fais je marche
en arrière maman arrête de faire sans
pourquoi des ports la loi
on est bon pour une bataille c'est quoi
votre métier
c'est bien je me dire que nous sommes
des moissonneurs dame égarés
[Musique]
mieux vaut éviter de mal à jouer trop
facile